what advice would you give to Young
Folks
what advice would I give in high school
and college that are
um thinking of how to make a their way
in this world
if you haven't already can you
can you define what you have an innate
ability for
and match that with what you're willing
to hustle to get
sometimes
we have an innate ability but we don't
want to work for it we take it for
granted
and we end up doing something that may
work I pay the bills I get a spy day to
day
but we don't really like it we have
trouble finding a way to enjoy it
definitely don't love it
and then sometimes
we don't know what our innate ability is
and we're hustling and working our tail
off and breaking a sweat to do something
that we really aren't that
good at
on an n a level
and that's a good challenge
and you can
work and become good at something
that you don't have an innate ability
for but
if you can match those two what do you
have an innate ability to do because we
have an innate ability to do when we do
that well we do kind of enjoy it yeah
and one of the things that requires us
to kind of be really honest with
yourself
at what your innate ability is because
oftentimes there's a lot of noise when
you're growing up people telling you
what you're good at not good at like
really you have to look at yourself
listen to yourself that inner
like a deep rigorous self-analysis of
what am I actually good at why would I
hope to be good at but what I'm actually
good at right
and then if you look at that and you can
define those two
hopefully
there's a you can you can activate it in
a way where there's demand for what you
supply